she's mine  [Music]  [Music]  maybe scum trash refuse that didn't fit  into the system  until someone had the bright idea  they're recycling us to serve science  [Music]  the arts are not in our favor  but when my work is accomplished when  perfection isn't she in - then what  highway dad I know I look like a witch  you're foxy and you know it this mission  came Turner ashamed to some type of  glory I can't do this flying around them  you lied to us  [Music]  the sensation moving backwards even  though I'm moving forwards getting  further from what's getting nearer  [Applause]  [Music]  there's nothing to fear everything's  gonna be fine yes  break the laws of nature you pay for it  [Music]  you  you